a large percentage of what people will
contribute to something is sometimes
it's as much a donation in support of a
relationship as it is a donation in
support of a cause what we wanted to be
sure to do was make sure that for the
motivated person who's got a target and
a goal that that what we were
engineering was an incredible tool box
for them to use all of our best ideas
that we've ever had and even to source
from other people by surfing around in
the site effective ways of taking their
motivation and their energy and you know
leveraging it into really good
productivity in terms of their personal
fundraising so on the one hand you want
to supply the motivated person with
everything they need to do a really good
job the next ring out is people who
might not have a specific connection so
for organizations we think one of the
things that's really potent is the idea
of in some ways doing what Obama did
which is take people who are already
donors to you and turn them into small
fundraisers for you you know I mean if a
person is capable of giving 50 bucks
themselves but it's really easy for them
to reach out to their family and friends
and just on the strength of personal
relationships say could I get you know
10 more people to donate 50 bucks then
they've just multiplied their own
capacity by 10 times anyone who is
involved in fundraising will tell you
that that kind of multiplying effect has
huge ramifications